une journée aux allures de campagne
présidentielle en géorgie ce mardi une
double élections sénatoriales cruciales
s'y déroulent
donald trump et joe biden se rendent sur
place pour soutenir leurs candidats
respectifs au sénat vous voterez pour
des journaux sauf fait raphael warnock
vous en verrez deux sénateurs qui se
battront pour vous en ce moment vous
avez deux sénateurs qui pensent qu'il ne
travaille pas pour vous il travaille
pour trump je suis sérieux pensez-y à
vous avez deux sénateurs qui pensent que
leur loyauté et envers trump à anvers la
géorgie vous avez deux sénateurs qui
pensent avoir prêté serment à donald
trump à la constitution des états unis
l'enjeu est de taille si les deux
candidats démocrates sont élus
démocrates et républicains auront alors
50 sièges chacun au sénat ce sera à la
future vice-présidente kamala harris de
départager les votes et donc de faire
pencher la balance du côté de son parti
dans le même temps donald trump refuse
toujours de reconnaître la victoire de
son adversaire à la présidentielle
selon les révélations du washington post
le président sortant aurait appelé le
secrétaire d'état de géorgie pour lui
demander de trouver des votes en sa
faveur
un élu républicain qui confirment la
défaite de trump dans cet état il est
assez clair qu'il n'a malheureusement
pas gagné je dis cela en tant que
républicain mais en tant que secrétaire
d'état je peux dire avec certitude que
le président trump n'a pas gagné l'état
de géorgie je ne prends pas vraiment de
décision ce que je fais c'est suivre la
loi et suivre les faits les chiffres
sont les chiffres et les chiffres que
nous avons communiqué sont factuellement
correct l'obstination du président
sortant a nié sa défaite va-t-elle jouer
en sa défaveur
en tout cas sur le papier en géorgie les
républicains partent favoris c'était un
as pas élu de démocrates au sénat depuis
20 ans